le tartre gaudran 31 habitants est la
commune la moins peuplée des ivelines
une des phrases cultes de la ville
plante le décor ici il y a plus de
chevaux que d'habitants pour les
élections municipales ne cherchez pas de
panneau d'affichage puisqu'il n'y a
qu'une seule liste celle de Bernard
lerou m sortant qui entamerait alors son
deuxè mandat vous faites une campagne
non non oui je vais faire déjà mon
adjointe à à formuler une let sur
laquelle mon un petit peu ce que ce qu'
ce qu'on veut faire et puis on les
distribuera dans dans les boîtes aux
lettres âgé de 65 ans né à versaill et
retraité de la sécurité sociale Bernard
lerou est arrivé à tartre gaudran en
2005 ah une chose que je voulais savoir
la la fermeture des bureaux de H 20h
c'est 20h ou 18h 20h tu es sûr parce que
j'ai vu un truc sur Internet pour les
communes de moins de 3500 habitants
c'est je crois que c'est 18he dans les
communes les élections se préparent et
tout est fait pour respecter la stricte
confidentialité des 42 inscrits sur les
listes électorales là j'ai installé un
isoloir parce que c'est pas facile
amovible donc on a monté ça après on va
monter le les rideaux pour que chacun
puisseisoler et voter cette personne
constitue la liste du maire sortant qui
se dit sans étiquette un des enjeux du
moment l'assaainissement de la commune
je trouve que le que maire c'est un
c'est un rôle de de chef d'entreprise
déjà et c'est pas toujours facile parce
que moi au départ moi je faisais que de
l'informatique et quand on m'a dit tu
veux être maire j'ai dit pourquoi pas
mais c'est pas c'est pas très facile
parce que
l'urbanisme les textes moi je
connaissais pas du tout on essaie
d'apprendre sur place du côté des
habitants on semble plutôt satisfait de
son action même s'il reste toujours une
ou deux choses à améliorer peut-être un
tout petit quelque chose devant la la
route parce que les gens vont un petit
peu vite alors je crois qu'ils vont s'en
occuper parce que les personnes les les
les véhicules vont un peu vite en 2007
le tartre gaudran avait reçu la Marianne
du civisme pour son fort taux de
participation aux élections présidentiel
près de 90 %. un taux qui le maire
l'espère sera aussi élevé lors de ses
prochaines élections municipales en 2008
plus de 92 % des électeurs s'étaient
déplacés aux
urnes